bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
troisième cours de paléontologie des
vertébrés
la dernière fois nous avons donc parler
de des poissons osseux notamment des
actes inoke terry giat et des sarko t'es
rien nous avons vu comment elle pisto
steger illustrait la transition entre
les poissons sarko terry gien et les
tétrapodes sarko parisien et nous avions
terminé sur xo stega à canto stega donc
les premiers tétrapodes les premiers les
premiers animaux qu'on peut appeler des
amphibiens
du coup et tout aux yeux c'est une
lancia qui était un peu leur équivalent
dans sur le continent africain
donc on continue cette fois avec la
classification des tétrapodes qui sera
en fait plus ou moins une classification
des amphibiens cette classification
étant essentiellement basée sur
l'anatomie des vertèbres donc ici vous
avez l'origine des tétrapodes est ici
vous avez les amniotes donc ce qu'on
appellerait des tétrapodes non
amphibiens ici l'art entre les
tétrapodes et les omnia ii vous avez les
branches de l'arbre qui représente les
amphibiens dont vous avez ici aux dégâts
à la base et vous avez les technos pont
deal qui sont parmi les plus les plus
abondants des tétrapodes amphibiens
qu'on puisse trouver
donc vous voyez ici là le terme
amphibiens et plus ou moins défini comme
étant tout ce qui a entre le noeud
thévenot secondes il est le noeud
tétrapodes et vous aurez et nous verrons
ne terminerons avec la transition en
fait entre les amphibiens et les amis
note qui passe par un groupe peu qu'on
appelle par convenance les reptiles
yomtov
et lorsque vous voyez représenté ici par
des parts des formes géométriques de
couleur c'est l'anatomie des vertèbres
donc les vertèbres des amphibiens sont
divisés en plusieurs parties elles sont
directement héritée de l'anatomie des
vertèbres des sarko t'es rien donc on
trouve on trouve en haut on trouve comme
chez les ch et tous les animaux ont un
arc
normal mais ce qui est intéressant à
regarder c'est le centre sommes donc le
centrum est en deux parties
donc la partie le corps de la vertèbre
et en deux parties vous avez cette
partie convoi l'avant et qui elle
intéressante et vous avez cette partie
qu'on voit à l'arrière qui est le plus
gros centre
donc en fait l'inter centre se trouve au
milieu et à l'avant et le pleure au
centre se trouve légèrement en retrait
et légèrement sur les côtés donc vous
avez un intéressante au milieu et 2
pleuraux centre sur les côtés et ce
qu'on voit en fait c'est que les
tétrapodes ont commencé leur évolution
avec un tout petit peu leur centre et un
gros intéressante et ça c'est
généralement associée à une morphologie
plutôt faible de la vertèbre enfin une
faible résistance à la gravité de la
vertèbre
ce qui fait qu'on interprète ça plutôt
comme un mode de vie comme reflétant un
mode de vie aquatique et plus les
tétrapodes vont s'approcher de la
condition amniotes et plus le plus gros
centre va devenir important donc chez
les reptiles you more fonds va avoir la
morphologie dit en blu mer ou
intéressante et leurs centres sont
quasiment exactement de la même taille
et contribue au centrum de la vertèbre
de façon quasiment égal et la vertèbre
va se renforcer chez les amis est encore
plus jusqu'à ce que le pdt leur centre
de vienne dominant voire même que
l'inter centre disparaître qu'on
disparaisse complètement chez les
mammifères par exemple il n'y a plus du
tout de traces de l'interface entre donc
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs il faudrait plutôt
représenté l'inter centre en bas ici en
fait il va il va disparaître mais plutôt
en position ventrale pas en position
dorsale d'ailleurs mais ce n'est pas
vraiment important l'important c'est de
voir le rapport de dominant sans fait
entre les deux donc chez les amphibiens
en fait on va surtout avoir des taxons
qui vont avoir l'intérêt centre l'intér
centre dominant avec des variations
intéressantes qui vont permettre de
faire la classification par exemple
celle et stéréo ce pont deal dont on
parlera il va y avoir un intérêt centre
plus que dominant l'inter centre va être
l'unique
composants de la vertèbre et puis on va
avoir en évoluant du côté des lices
amphibiens on va avoir une convergence
en fête avec les amis note ou le pleure
au centre va devenir aussi dominant donc
on va voir les ans ça chez les
amphibiens et chez leur groupe frère
lady soro folie mais nous allons voir ça
un peu plus dans le détail donc déjà
petit rappel de ce que sont les
amphibiens les amphibiens en fait ils
ont tous les caractères qu'on retrouve
déjà chez xo stega et à canto stega à
part le nombre de doigts aux mains je
rappelle que quand toaster gaity st gall
et lui doit aux mains mais les
amphibiens ce qu'on appelle les
amphibiens donc là j'ai mis des
guillemets parce que ce qu'on appelle
les amphibiens vous venez de le voir en
fait ça comprend aussi les ancêtres des
amis haute donc des animaux qui sont
plus qu'ils sont en fait plus proche d
amy est qu'ils ne le sont de ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui les amphibiens et
qui sont les lys amphibiens l'hélice
amphibia donc les amphibiens ça avec des
guillemets c'est un groupe encore une
fois anatomiquement homogène mais
phylogénétiquement pas très homogène
donc anatomiquement il est homogène
pourquoi parce que chez les amphibiens
vous allez systématiquement ou presque
systématiquement retrouver un museau
très arrondi un crâne très plat des yeux
au sommet du crâne qui permettent de
guetter les proies en ayant la tête
juste au dessus de l'eau vous allez
avoir le candide occipital donc
l'articulation de la tête avec le corps
qui va être concave donc ce que vous
voyez là donc cette forme ici concave
alors que chez les amniotes il va être
convaincre s'il va être en forme de
boule
donc ça c'est très typique de ce qu'on
appelle les amphibiens de manière
générale condyle occipital concave
vous allez avoir cette ornementations le
crâne va être perforé de plein de petits
trous qui sont on le pense des foramen
sensorielle qui permettait de de sentir
la pression de l'eau comme chez les
crocodiles moderne les dans son
labyrinthe aux dons ce qui veut ce qui
d'ailleurs rappelle le fait que les
amphibiens bazzo sont souvent appelés
laisse tes gosses et fall ou les
bientôt donc est ce qu'il ya
d'intéressant avec cette morphologie
labyrinthe aux dons tu sais qu'on peut
la retracer jusqu'au jusqu'au sarcopte
est rien et cette morphologie la bière
attendant elle va elle va être sujet à
variations on va voir notamment que les
grenouilles moderne enfin les
grenouilles les salamandres et les
crapauds modernes n'ont pas de dents
labyrinthe aux dons donc c'est vraiment
typique des amphibiens bazzo et on a un
caractère plutôt intéressant qu'on va
retrouver chez certains amphibiens bazzo
et notamment les technos pondent il ça
va être la présente de la présence de
quatre doigts seulement sur les mains
sur les mains uniquement pas sur les
pieds des pieds aux cinq doigts mais les
mains pendant que quatre
et ça c'est quelque chose qu'on va
retrouver chez les amphibiens moderne et
enfin la métamorphose donc là qui va
être notamment marquée par la présence
de branchies chez les ch et les larves
donc ses branchies elles vont être
visibles parce qu'elles ont elles sont
attachées à des arcs branche chiots et
ses arcs branché où ils sont aussi fier
plus ou moins aussi fier donc si on
trouve un tout petit individu dans le
registre fossile qui a des arcs
branchaud on a généralement tendance à
l'interpréter comme étant la larve d'un
individu plus gros fin d'une espèce dont
les adultes seraient plus gros des fois
ça arrive qu'on ait des néoténie donc ce
qu'on appelle ce conte ce qu'on pourrait
qualifier d adultes de forme juvénile
comme ça se passe chez lac soloq il ya
certaines espèces comme ça qu'ils sont
identifiés comme étant des adultes nés
aux techniques et non pas des des
juvéniles mais le tout le tous ensemble
cela montre bien que à un moment du
développement de ces amphibiens bazzo il
y avait une métamorphose
donc on a pas d'épreuve de métamorphose
pour toutes les espèces d'amphibiens
bazzo évidemment il y en a certains qui
sont connus que par un seul crâne donc
évidemment vous avez pas voilà vous avez
pas l'inventer non plus mais mais on a
suffisamment quand même de ces
amphibiens bazzo pour lesquelles on a
retrouvé des possibles larves et des
adultes pour dire que la métamorphose
semble être une caractéristique des
tétrapodes bazzo et notamment de ces
amphibiens donc donc leur biologie en
fait c'est pour ça que je que j'utilise
en fait finalement ce système qui n'est
pas phylogénétique mais qui est plutôt
basée sur le fait que
morphologiquement on a des groupements
cohérent comme les amphibiens même si
phylogénétiquement ça veut pas dire
grand chose parce que la biologie de ces
animaux en tout et pour tout c'était
celle d'un amphibien moderne quoi donc
donc on a on a plus vite fait de les
décrire comme étant des amphibiens que
les décrivant en disant tétrapodes non
amniotes comme on aurait pu dire avec
les sarko quiérysiens tétrapodes amorphe
non tétrapodes ou enfin bref voilà on
finit par rajouter du jargon du jargon
du jargon et on passe à côté du message
en fait voilà le problème d'utiliser
tout ce vocabulaire phylogénétique c'est
qu'on rajoute beaucoup de jargon donc on
rajoute beaucoup d'incompréhension pour
finalement perdre un message qui est le
message paléo biologique
si je vous dis c'est un amphibien si je
vous dis que rinne ai su qu ici donc du
permien d'afrique du sud est un
amphibien vous visualisez immédiatement
l'animal si je vous dis que rien
n'excuse est un tétrapodes non
amniotique enfin bref qu'est ce que vous
voyez vous voyez pas grand chose
déjà même amiotte c'est pas forcément
dit que vous savez ce que ça veut dire
et là si on rajoute tétrapodes non
amniotes on est perdu on est perdu quoi
amphibiens c'est simple c'est rapide
c'est rapide mais il faut savoir que ce
n'est pas le terme phylogénétiquement
consacré et c'est tout au moins on sait
de quoi on parle et le groupe
alors il ya plusieurs il ya plusieurs
grands groupes d'amphibiens bazot il ya
notamment les laisse tereos pondent il
ya les technos pondent il et puis il va
y avoir les reptiles you more of donc
laisser les technos pondent il comment
on les reconnaît eh ben on les reconnaît
très facilement bon déjà ils ont un
crâne d'amphibiens donc plat avec les
yeux sur le sur le dessus et et avec des
petits des petites ponctuation sur toute
la surface et un candide occipital
complexe
mais on les reconnaît surtout parmi les
autres amphibiens parce qu'ils ont c'est
énorme fenêtre qu'on appelle les
fenêtres inter terry gohi diène donc
c'est énorme fenêtre sur le palais qui
sont très très caractéristique qu'on
voit très bien ici sur le crâne de par
auto sus ici du trias d'afrique du sud
donc les ici je vous donne un exemple du
trias mais les technos pont dillon les
trouve depuis le carbonifère et c'est un
des groupes d'amphibiens base au sein
des groupes de stelios et fall qui a
perdu le plus longtemps puisque les
derniers représentants de ce groupe se
sont éteints au crétacé en australie
donc on est finalement on n'est pas
passé si loin que ça de pouvoir vous
rencontrer des technos pondent il on
n'est passé qu'à 60 millions 1 15 70
millions d'années de 2,2 de pouvoir voir
des technos pondent il quant à la
fonction de ses fenêtres il est probable
qu'elles aient servi d'insertion
musculaire il est probable qu'elle ait
servi à quelque elle est notamment que
ses muscles qui s'insérait là-dedans
avait quelque chose à voir avec la
déglutition puisque les technos pondent
il enfin les amphibiens ont des façons
de daval et qui ne sont pas du tout les
mêmes que chez les amniotes vous
connaissez peut-être par exemple le cas
des grenouilles en fin de certaines
grenouilles qui utilisent leurs yeux
pour pouvoir pousser la nourriture dans
au fond de leur gauche donc leurs yeux
traverse le palais ils ont des muscles
qui permettent de rétracter le globe
oculaire est en fait c'est la rétraction
du globe oculaire qui va traverser le
palais et poussé la nourriture dans leur
gorge
donc je pense pas que ce que ça a été le
cas avec les thèmes de ce pont dean mais
il y avait certainement des muscles ici
qu'il y avait à voir avec la déglutition
et aussi avec le fait qu'il y à un joint
intracrânien donc à une articulation
intracrânienne ici du coup le museau
peut se plier par rapport à la boîte
crânienne et sas peut-être que ses
muscles avait aussi à voir avec ça et
les technos pont deal comme je le disais
ils sont extrêmement diversifié
particulièrement en afrique surtout en
afrique du sud dans le karoo on retrouve
des technos pondent il
par dizaines voire par centaines et là
je vous donne que quelques petits
exemples alors on a de tout un niveau
technos pondent il donc des plus petits
comme brumi stega donc qui est très
connu pour pour être ce squelette qui
partageaient un terrier avec ici le tri
nac ce don qui est un reptile malien
donc brumi stega qui était suffisamment
petit pour rentrer dans le terrier
d'interac site jusqu'au plus gros comme
le fameux précieux du lesotho qui a été
présenté par sébastien steyer dans son
livre la terre avant les dinosaures que
jeu dont je vous recommande la lecture
évidemment donc le ce précieux du
lesotho dont vous pouvez voir ici la
taille impressionnante donc c'est juste
un petit bout de mâchoire mais ce petit
bout de mâchoire légèrement arrondi à la
surface à la surface ponctué de petits
trous avec les dents labyrinthes aux
dons bref ce précieux du lesotho il n'y
a pas de doute sur le fait que c'était
un amphibien il a des grosses dans vos
mérienne ce qui indique qu'il appartient
à un groupe de temenos pondent il
il me semble que c'est laid mastodonte
au mastodonte aux russes mais je suis
pas sur mais enfin ça va ça montre qu'il
appartient à un groupe de temenos
pondent il connut et du coup sachant les
proportions des technos pondent il en
général ça ne vous donnerai ce qui a
probablement été le plus gros amphibiens
qui a jamais existé
voilà là on est beaucoup plus gros que
sur la salamandre géante du japon la wii
2 chine beaucoup plus gros ou même
d'amérique d'ailleurs je crois que c'est
là je crois que c'est la salamandre
géante de chine la plus grosse des trois
mais bref on est beaucoup plus gros de
toute façon que ça là on est sur un gros
amphibiens de plus de 6 mètres de long
probablement donc on a de tout du plus
petit au plus gros on a parmi les plus
anciens stéréos pondent il donc je vous
ai parlé tout à l'heure les stéréos
pondent ils ce sont les amphibiens qui
ont l'inter centre qui domine largement
sur les pleurs au centre vous voyez si
les deux plus gros centres qui sont tout
petits petits et qui vont éventuellement
disparaître donc cédé stéréos pondi l'on
trouve les plus anciens dans le père
bien supérieur par exemple en namibie
ici est en fait leur intéressante très
très gros
montre que ces stéréos pondent ils
étaient plutôt des animaux aquatiques et
c'est pour ça ici que le précieux du
lesotho et reconstituer même si on a qu
une mâchoire on le reconstitue
raisonnablement avec des to petites
jambes parce que c'était probablement à
l'animal essentiellement aquatique est
pas vraiment qu'ils devaient pas
vraiment se mouvoir sur terre en fait
donc et on a aussi un autre groupe qui
est important c'est celui d'eddy soro
floride
donc les 10 euros id que c'est le
contraire c'est pas l'heure intéressante
qui domine c'est leur plus gros centre
ce qui est un caractère alors soit qui
pourrait les relier aux amniotes soit
qui pourrait les relier aux amphibiens
moderne l'hélice amphibiens et on pense
qu'ils sont plutôt relié aux amphibiens
moderne des parce que l'ornementation de
leur crâne et plus tôt fait de bosses
donc ils ont un crâne qui est très
ornementé mais au lieu d'avoir une
surface perforé en fait ils ont une
surface qui est plutôt bulbeuses voyez
avec des petits bulbes et tout ça et ça
ça c'est plutôt quelque chose qu'on
retrouve chez les salamandres
ils ont aussi des dents qui ont deux
cuts speed dont deux petites pointes et
ça c'est aussi un caractère qu'on
retrouve chez les salamandres et c'est
même dans son p 10 et les dons qu'elles
ont un genre de racines si vous préférez
et ça c'est aussi un caractère qu'on
retrouve chez les salamandres donc pour
ces trois raisons
lady soro floride pourraient être les
ancêtres plus ou moins directe des des
amphibiens moderne
on voit aussi qu'il ya une certaine
tendance à la miniaturisation les 10
euros floride sont vraiment de tout
petit petit amphibien et on voit les
grands yeux donc à crâne très grand
trait à l'aspect très juvénile est très
léger comme on voit chez les grenouilles
moderne par exemple donc ça pourrait
repousser l'origine des lices amphibiens
du mois la racine évolue-t-il des amphis
là jusqu'au carbonifère dont je viens de
modifier un petit peu la slide parce
qu'il y avait une erreur ici c'était
écrit trias non non c'est bel et bien le
l'origine des 10 euros id c'est le
carbonifère donc ça pourrait repousser
l'origine des lices amphibiens jusqu'au
carbonifère et donc ses systèmes noces
pondi l'île sont si abondant en afrique
du sud qu'on va les utiliser
abondamment pour la stratigraphie mais
ça ce sera pour une prochaine fois
c'est juste pour vous montrer que voilà
on a on a une très très bonne idée de la
distribution bio stratigraphique de ces
technos pondent il donc on les utilise
abondamment dans ce but là donc
maintenant les lys amphibiens donc le
groupe des amphibiens moderne où on va
retrouver les grenouilles et les
crapauds et les salamandres et bien ce
groupe délice amphibiens il est
caractérisée par un grand nombre de
traits la plupart d'entre eux étant
crânien évidemment donc ça va être déjà
l'absence de dans l'habit râteau dont tu
donc des dents p10 et les ouïes des
dents bis q speed oui mais pas lundi
râteau dont tu le crâne va être aussi
simplifié alors non pas que la
morphologie du crâne soit simple à
comprendre mais par rapport à un
amphibien basale en fait que vous voyez
représenté ici en fait le crâne des
lices amphibiens a perdu de nombreuses
au donc notamment toute la série d'os
qui se trouvent autour de l'oeil le
lacrymal préfrontal post frontale et
post orbitaire et jus galles tout ça
s'est perdu donc le crâne en fait vous
voyez l'oeil est quasiment fin l'oeil
est très très grand sur ce crâne sur ses
craintes de lys amphibiens et si vous
regardez le palais le palais a aussi
perdu de nombreux os donc c'est ce qui
fait dire que le crâne est simplifié aux
contrats du coup ça le rend plutôt
difficile à interpréter parce qu'il ya
les eaux qu'on devrait trouver à
certains endroits ne s'y trouve pas là
par exemple vous voyez le pro ethik lots
piste aux tic sont visibles sur la face
dorsale du crâne alors qu'ils sont pas
censés l'être normalement donc ça c'est
assez particulier
l'hélice amphibiens aussi ont perdu le
foramen pinéale alors foramen pinéale
dont j'ai pas trop parler jusqu'à
présent mais si vous revenez en arrière
jusqu'à vous pouvez retourner même
jusqu'à se tenait jusqu'à jusqu à l
piste host et j'ai même jusqu'à un
sténopé theron même si j'en ai pas
vraiment parler mais vous pouvez aller
voir depuis depuis au moins les sarko
parisien et sinon depuis même l'origine
des vertébrés en général les
les vertébrés ont presque toujours un
petit trou sur le sommet du crâne qui
s'appelle le foramen pinéale et ce faux
ramène pinéale donne passage un petit
organe qui s'appelle l'oeil pinéale qui
est relié à la glande pinéale et tout ça
permet aux animaux de voir les
différences entre le jour et la nuit
ce devoir la longueur des jours et du
coup d'estimer les saisons c'est
finalement ce qui sert d'horloge
d'horloge biologique sa règle en fait
tous les rythmes biologiques basés sur
un système de calendrier biologique
grâce à cet oeil pinéale qui perd qui
voit en fait la différence entre le jour
et la nuit et la longueur du jour et la
longueur des nuits donc c'est un foramen
final il est très important
biologiquement et donc il est
remarquable de le voir disparaître chez
les chez les amphibiens
ce qui ne veut pas dire que l'oeil
pinéale est perdue ils ont toujours un
petit oeil pinéale mais il est très
réduit et il n'est plus exposées à
l'extérieur en fait ils voient le jour
mais à travers le crâne et non plus à
travers un petit trou donc ce forum n
pinéale ils n'existent plus donc ça
c'est aussi un caractère très important
et on en avait déjà parlé il n'y a que
quatre doigts aux mains ce qui est aussi
un caractère qu'on trouve chez les
technos pontil dans ce qui permet aussi
de connecter les technos pont deal aux
amphibiens hollis amphibiens et le plus
vieux lice amphibiens est africain il
vient de madagascar et là où ça devient
un curieux en fait c'est que c'est déjà
une grenouille
donc c'est ryad au battra cus qui nous
vient du trias de madagascar et ria de
battre accusent comme vous pouvez le
voir comme les grenouilles triadou
patrac us n'a pas de côtes triade au
battre accuse un curieuse hausse en
forme de u à la place du bassin qui
s'appelle lure hostile
donc c'est écrit ici et qui est typique
qui est typique des grenouilles des des
batraciens et triade patrac us n'a pas
de queue comme les grenouilles les
grenouilles non contrairement aux
salamandres n'ont pas de queue alors
après les membres sont pas encore tout à
fait adaptée au saut ils sont légèrement
enfin les pattes arrières sont
légèrement allongée mais par contre vous
voyez que le tibia fibula sont pas
fusionner alors que le tibia et la
figure
là sont fusionnés chez celle et les
grenouilles moderne
donc ce que vous voyez là et là c'est
pas ça le tibia fibula ça c'est
l'astragale et le calcanéum donc ce sont
les os de la cheville qui sont allongés
et qui tiennent une place fonctionnel
qui tienne pour fonction la fonction du
tibia fibula mais le tibia et de la
fibula ils sont ici ont fusionné mais ça
c'est votre fémur et si vous voyez luro
style donc
donc voilà ça veut dire donc ça veut
dire qu au trias on a non seulement déjà
des lices amphibiens mais qu'en plus
c'est lisse amphibiens était déjà divisé
en grenouille et par déduction il y
avait aussi certainement déjà des
salamandres et il y avait certainement
déjà ce qu'on appelle des cécilien c'est
à dire des petits amphibiens reptiles
amphibiens fouisseurs qui ressemble
beaucoup à des verts vu de dehors mais
qui ont typiquement ce crâne la vue de
dedans donc
donc tout ça ça avaient déjà
probablement diverger tous ces lignes et
avaient déjà probablement diverger au
trias et ça veut dire qu'il ya une
origine profonde des lices amphibiens
dans le paléozoïque même si pour
l'instant on a zéro fossiles qui le
documente et petits faits notables c'est
le c'est l'existence de cette petite
grenouille qui a été découverte dans un
rare c'est dans un dépôt de cratère de
volcan fait donc il ya un lac qui s'est
développée dans le cratère du volcan et
à l'intérieur de ce lac de volcans
vivait une grenouille et cette
grenouille c'est fossilisés et quand on
la retrouvait elle a été baptisée du nom
de vulcano battre accuse mandela y donc
vulcano battra cus la grenouille du
volcan et demandent des laïcs d'après
nelson mandela puisqu'elle a été
découverte en afrique du sud
donc c'est mais celle là elle date du
crétacé donc il y avait déjà comment on
sait déjà qu'il y avait des grenouilles
à l'époque donc c'est pas une grosse
surprise et d'ailleurs vous pouvez voir
que le tibia le fit lula sont fusionnés
et que l'astragale et le cannet hommes
sont allongés donc c'était une
grenouille qui était capable de sauter
et ici vous pouvez voir son héros style
l'absence de cotes très typique des
grenouilles
on passe maintenant au deuxième grand
groupe de tétrapodes ce deuxième grand
groupe après les amphibiens c'est celui
des amniotes donc le groupe d amniotes
c'est celui là n'a pas de petit
guillemets parce que les amis notes sont
effectivement tous descendants d'un seul
et unique ancêtres en commun du mois
pour autant qu'on sache donc celui-là
n'a pas de guillemets c'est un groupe
qui est non seulement un atomique mans
cohérent mais qui en plus philogène
phylogénétiquement a du sens c'est à
mignotte
ils sont reconnus à ils sont les
distingue des amphibiens bas par
beaucoup de caractère déjà le fait que
hills et un crâne qui n'est pas plat qui
n'est qu'il ne soit pas plat donc ce
crâne au lieu d'être plat il est
beaucoup plus alors on dit qu'il est
plus profond c'est à dire qu'il n'est
plus haut
en fait au lieu d'être aplati les il est
au de fait les yeux sont placés sur les
côtés
donc les orbites sont sur les côtés du
crâne et la surface et lisse il n'y a
pas de petites ponctuation qui servent
normalement un à sentir les vibrations
de l'eau la surface est lisse il n'y a
pas de ligne sensorielle donc si ça j'en
ai pas trop parler mais si on retourne
en arrière je peux vous montrer ce que
c'est les lignes sensorielles en fait ce
sont ces lignes que vous voyez là vous
avez peut-être cru que c'était que
c'était quelque chose de tout à fait
anecdotique en le voyant la première
fois c'est vrai que c'est pas facile à
voir mais céline sensorielles en fait
c'est le sait finalement ce qui donne
une grande partie la sensation justement
à la peau qui recouvrait le crâne ici
donc ça c'est couple est en fête avec
ses petites ponctuation donc céline
sensorielle c'est un truc qu'on trouvait
déjà chez les poissons chez les sarcomes
térésiens et qui était encore présent
chez les amphibiens mais qui est perdu
chez les amiotte le aussi on à la perte
de du de l'encoche aux tic donc perte de
l'encoche aux tic qui a remplacé par un
méga auditif externe c'est à dire par le
trou qu'on appelle chez nous les
oreilles
voilà donc l'encoche le ticket remplacer
l'encoche la grosse différence en fait
c'est que l'encoche aux tic
elle est située au sommet du crâne alors
que le meilleur auditif externe il est
situé sous le crâne
alors on sait pas trop comment ça s'est
passé cette transition il est fort
probable que ce qu'on appelle la
membrane tympanique sur l'encoche aux
tic n'a rien à voir avec ce qu'on
appelle la membrane la panique à
l'intérieur du meilleur auditif externe
de la même façon qu'on a découvert
récemment que la membrane tympanique
entre les soro psid et celle des
mammifères ne naît pas la même donc la
membrane tympanique c'est probablement
quelque chose qui a évolué plein de fois
en fait les reptiles les reptiles ont
une membrane la panique mais elle n'a
rien à voir avec la membrane tympanique
des mammifères donc même la même là on
peut même pas dire que la membrane la
panique de semer à auditif externe là
c'est la même que celle qu'on trouve
chez les animaux moderne mais en tout
cas le trou pour l'oreille lui c'est le
même voilà un autre caractère
intéressant sur le crâne c'est le thé
rigaud id
donc c'est un os qui était plutôt
anecdotique on en a un petit peu parlé
avec les fenêtres perrigault id sur le
palais des des technos pont deal
mais cette hausse de perrigo idylle
passe en fait de tout plat
si on repart si on repart un peu en
arrière voyez le losc perrigault id
c'est ce gros cela et vous voyez qu ici
qu'il est tout plat
il passe de tout plat à voa en volume et
si vous voyez et chez les amniotes quand
on regarde le crâne sur le côté
généralement le stéréoïdes est visible
et est tellement gros en fait qu'il est
visible en vue latérale comme ça du
crâne
donc pourquoi ça arrive ça c'est tout
simplement parce que quand on vit dans
l'eau comme un amphibien ou quand on
chasse au moins dans l'eau comme un
amphibien eh bien on compte en fait sur
l'effet de ponction de la bouche soit un
mouvement de pompes afin d'aspirer sa
proie donc en fait le simple ouvre le
simple fait d'ouvrir sa bouche dans
l'eau aspire l'eau à l'intérieur de la
bouche et donc fait venir faire entrer
la proie sans effort dans la bouche donc
un chasseur qui chassent dans l'eau a
besoin de beaucoup de forces pour
arriver à ouvrir la bouche pour pouvoir
contrer la différence de pression entre
l'eau et l'air qui à l intérieur de sa
bouche mais par contre il n'a pas besoin
de beaucoup de forces pour fermer la
bouche
par contre un chasseur un petit
prédateurs comme comme l'étaient les les
tout premiers amniotes un petit prêt
attar terrestre lui il n'a pas besoin de
beaucoup de forces pour ouvrir la bouche
parce que l'air à l'intérieur de sa
bouche est à la même pression que l'air
à l'extérieur
par contre il a besoin de beaucoup de
forces pour fermer la bouche parce qu'il
est en train de chasser une proie qui va
essayer de se barrer et il n'a pas la
force de l'eau la pression de l'eau pour
pousser cette proie au fond de sa gorge
donc il lui faut des gros muscles
perrigault id il lui faut des gros
muscles pour pouvoir fermer la bouche et
ses muscles
ce sont les muscles qui s'insère sur le
losc et rigaud et qu'on appelle donc les
muscles perrigault ide et on va voir en
fait ça c'est au début de l'histoire des
amniotes donc au début de l'histoire des
amniotes c'est le muscle perrigault id
qui va faire le plus gros du travail
mais au fur et à mesure qu'ils vont
évoluer les amiotte ils vont inventer de
nouvelles manières de fermer la bouche
et ça va ça va notamment être liés au
développement des fausses temporal qu'on
verra juste après
donc ça c'est pour le crâne maintenant
pour les membres aussi de vienne se
transforme chez les a' mignotte
notamment parce que les amniotes sont
plus adaptés à la vie terrestre que ne
le sont les amphibiens donc déjà ils
sont capables de se reproduire sur terre
donc le truc le plus important à propos
des âmes iott c'est le fait qu'ils
pondent des oeufs est pas d eux juste
membraneux comme on voit chez les
amphibiens mais dea co qui sèche ou plus
ou moins sèche on va dire et c'est eux
sont dix neuf amniotique parce qu'ils
contiennent un liquide qui s'appelle la
muse et qui maintient en fait l'embryon
dans un environnement aquatique dans un
environnement à queue alors même que
l'oeuf lui-même n'est pas pondu en
environnement à que les amphibiens sont
obligés de pondre leurs oeufs dans un
milieu aquatique
alors que les amniotes ne le sont pas
c'est la différence on va dire
fondamentale entre amphibiens et
amniotes différence qui hélas est
purement anecdotique dans un contexte
paléontologique et c'est pour ça que
j'en parle que maintenant c'est parce
que on trouvera jamais de reyff
amniotique fossilisés c'est mort on
saura jamais jeudi on ne saura jamais
qui était le premier à pondre un oeuf
amniotique pour la simple et bonne
raison que c'est cette famille aux tic
il a zéro chance de se fossiliser
c'était probablement à 9 avec une
coquille
mol donc on trouvera jamais non plus
tout vaguement de coki dont bref voilà
c'est les la famille aux tic s'est pas
exactement quelque chose qui est très
pertinent en paléontologie donc c'est
pour ça que j'ai commencé d'abord par
les caractères crânien mais voilà l'oeuf
amniotique c'est le truc qui caractérise
évidemment les amniotes le plus vieil
oeuf qu'on ait retrouvé c'est même pas
un oeuf en fait c'est un embryon
recroquevillé sur lui même d'un petit
reptile qui s'appelle mais aux eaux
russes enfin d'un réseau rides mais
zozos rider mais on pense que c'est mais
aux eaux russes est raisonnablement mais
ce petit mais autorise des voiliers il
est il est enroulé comme s'ils étaient
impactées dans un oeuf
mais on n'a pas l'heur donc donc c'est
bien ça vous montre bien que voilà le
seul moyen de dire si un animal pont des
dec éventuellement d'arriver à retrouver
ce genre de petits fossile d'un bébé
recroquevillé sur lui même comme s'il
était empaqueté dans un oeuf mais l'oeuf
lui même ne se fossilise pas de même de
même chez les a menés au titre on a une
fécondation qui est interne au lieu de
la fécondation externe chez les
amphibiens donc il ya il ya un pénis et
il y as fécondation interne alors que
chez les amphibiens on va avoir
on va avoir plus tôt une fécondation
externe les oeufs vont être répondues et
fertilisé par le mal après la ponte
la peau est sèche donc elle est sèche et
recouvert port ce ton des cayes kératine
euse donc des écailles faite de kératine
comme chez les reptiles moderne mais
encore une fois il n'ya rien qui
garantit qu'il y avait des écailles
puisque c'est du tissus mous encore que
on va vous verrez sur le court sur l'été
sur l'évolution des synapses id on pense
qu'au début de leur évolution les
synapses ide avaient des écailles
donc si les synapses il avait des
écailles donc les ancêtres des
mammifères avec des écailles et que les
reptiles ont toujours des écailles
aujourd'hui ça veut dire que
probablement leurs ancêtres en commun
donc l'ancêtre des amis ott avait
probablement des écailles et puis on a
la présence d'une paupière mais qui est
probablement peut-être ou peut-être pas
hérité de des amphibiens on ne sait pas
je vous avais dit que les amphibiens il
avait dit ils avaient un canal lacrymal
qui permettait de sécréter des larmes et
ce depuis même avant les amphibiens ce
depuis certains poissons sarcopte est
rien donc il y avait probablement aussi
une paupière ou peut-être pas on ne sait
pas c'est pareil c'est du tissus mous et
on a évidemment des reins qui permettent
d'éliminer les déchets tout en
économisant l'eau puisqu'on n'a pas on
n'a pas besoin d'économiser l'eau quand
on vit dans l'eau mais est on peut
éliminer ces déchets un peu comme on
veut les poissons la plupart des
poissons moderne évacuent leurs déchets
par les branchies il utilise même pas lu
rinne pour évacuer leurs déchets roues
tout cas pas tous les déchets ils
utilisent ils utilisent surtout leurs
branches il les déchets sont excrétés
par les branchies voilà c'est plus le
cas avec les âmes note avec les amiotte
vous avez un système de reins assez
complexe qui permet de filtrer tout ça
est de récupérer l'eau surtout parce que
tout y est
et toutes ces adaptations c'est pour
économiser l'eau enfin c'est pour ces
pour accommoder l'absence d'eau d'une
façon ou d'une autre la fécondation
interne dans ça économise palau mais ça
permet de de contourner l'absence d'eau
quant au moment de la fécondation la
peau sèche c'est pour empêcher la perte
d'eau les reins c'est pour empêcher la
perte d'eau les paupières c'est pour
humidifier l'oeil pour qu'ils restent
fonctionnels malgré la sécheresse est
évidemment le fameux nautique c'est pour
remplacer le milieu aqueux pour
l'embryon
donc voilà il ya plein d'adaptation à au
milieu terrestre qui ont lieu chez les
âmes note donc c'est pour ça qu'on est
toujours dans le chapitre de l'eau à la
terre c'est parce que les amniotes en
fête la naissance d avenir ça va être le
dernier jalon on va dire de cette
transition depuis le milieu aquatique
jusqu'au milieu terrestre et on peut
parler d'une transition aquatique aux
mystères est simplement parce que j'ai
pas j'ai pas vraiment focalisé sur les
espèces qui sont retournés vivre dans
l'eau comme je disais il ya certains
stéréo ce pont deal qui sont partis
retourner vivre dans l'eau et genre bien
comme il faut genre perdre toute leur
jambe est retourné ressembler à des
anguilles quoi donc
donc évidemment c'est parce que je
focalise sur une ligne et en particulier
que je peux parler de transition de
de la mer à la terre mais cet essai de
transition donc le dernier jalon de
cette transition c'est les amniotes et
donc les amiotte sur leur squelette
on peut pas dire si le pont des dieux
par contre on peut voir sur leur
squelette qu'ils avaient d'autres
athlètes adaptation à vivre sur le sol
donc notamment le développement de ce
qu'on appelle l'axis donc maintenant on
a une tête qui est capable de bouger en
trois dimensions le le du coup le conte
du look si pital est adapté à ces
nouveaux mouvements et a désormais une
forme de boule
voilà ce qui permet donc de bouger dans
tous les sens donc c'est plus un conte
deal occipital concave comme on en avait
tout à l'heure mais maintenant on a un
qu'on dit loppsi pital convexe chez les
amphibiens on avait un candide occipital
concave et maintenant on a un qu'on dise
occipital qui est maintenant convaincre
l'une des adaptations les plus
importantes à la vie sur la terre ferme
c'est le développement d'une seconde
vertèbres sacré donc maintenant vous
n'avez plus une mais deux vertèbres qui
soutiennent le bassin qui attachent le
bassin à la colonne vertébrale et ça
c'est un nombre minimum chez les amis
haute puisque chez les amis at on va
avoir un développement du nombre de
vertèbres sacré qui va qui va aller 2-2
jusqu'à plusieurs dizaines chez les
oiseaux par exemple généralement on va
tourner entre 2 et 5
mais voilà ça peut ça peut monter jusqu
à des chiffres astronomiques notamment
chez les oiseaux et celle et chez les
grands dinosaures sauropodes aussi
d'ailleurs
les vertèbres donc on leur plus gros
centre qui est dominant ça on l'a déjà
vu qui est aussi une adaptation à la vie
terrestre
les vertèbres sont plus robustes en
ayant leur plus gros centre dominant les
amniotes apparaissent vers la fin du
carbonifère dont le sévère le
le milieu plutôt fin du carbonifère
qu'on voit les premiers amniotes
apparaître donc les du mois qu'on voit
apparaître cette combinaison la de
caractère qu'on pense être relié avec
l'apparition de l'oeuf amniotique
voilà donc cette ces adaptations un mode
de vie plus terrestre dans un milieu
plus sec dans c'est à partir de la fin
du carbonifère qu'ils apparaissent avec
par exemple paléo thirith avec ilo nos
musso si on va aussi voir apparaître en
parallèle d'autres espèces bas par
exemple les synapses id com com archéo
thirith par exemple qu'on va aussi voir
apparaître dans ces régions-là donc
l'amérique du nord la nouvelle écosse
c'est à la fin du carbonifère qu'on va
aussi voir apparaître archéo thirith
donc des animaux qu'on sait être relié
au synap si doux au sort au petit donc
les amniotes et des animaux qui ont 7
ces caractères la con qu'on pense être
relié à l'oeuf amniotique
mais évidemment on sera jamais sur
exactement deux camps l'oeuf amniotique
est apparue puisque tant qu'on n'aura
pas de preuve l'absence de preuve n'est
pas de preuve d'absence voilà on
prononcera toujours très embêté mais
vous voyez la cherchez pas les hôtes
iris on voit déjà que la saq 6 on voit
le les petits rigolos id bien ressortant
sous le crâne
il yaa nommé à auditif externe il n'y a
pas de deux encoches aux tic et on a un
candidat occipital qui est bien complexe
et ses premiers amiotte sont directement
descendu comme je le disais des reptiles
you more donc les reptiles you move qui
sont passés par une phase une phase en
blu mer où on avait à la fois le plus
gros centre et l'inter centre dominant
qu'on retrouve par exemple chez chez les
entre à cause or donc ce qu'on appelle
les en traque aux ordres qu'on ne
retrouve pareil que dans l'hémisphère
nord
on a aussi après on a des animaux que
comme les laisser mourir amorphe et les
dialectes aux morts qui vont développer
deux vertèbres sacré donc exactement
comme les amiotte ils vont avoir un
soutien terrestre plus important au
niveau de leurs vertèbres sacré par
contre ils vont conserver un crâne
relativement arrondie avec une surface
qui est toujours recouverts de petites
de petites perforations comme chez un
amphibien les lignes sensorielle vont
être plus ou moins absente plus ou moins
marqués on va dire gnrh elia dectot mort
fait sont complètement absentes et les
les orbites vont être beaucoup moins sur
le dessus du crâne elles vont être un
peu plus sur les côtés
bon le crâne conserve cette forme
généralement arrondi donc ça les orbites
sont pas totalement sur les côtés mais
elles sont généralement en tout cas ne
sont pas en position haute sur le crâne
elles sont le crâne n'est pas du tout
comme celui d'un crocodile c'est pas du
tout ça n'a plus rien à voir avec celui
d'un d'un amphibien donc
donc voilà cette transition mais cette
transition à la lieu essentiellement
dans l'hémisphère nord et c'est pour ça
que je n'en parle pas dans ces diapos
par contre ce dont je vais parler c'est
de la première grande radiation
évolutive des amniotes qui est elle par
contre très très bien documenté dans le
car ont donc le caroux c'est cette
grande étendue désertique qui se
trouvent en afrique du sud qui se trouve
vous voyez qui démarre à peu près au
niveau de johannesbourg et qui s'étend
presque jusqu'au cap
donc comme je le disais il ya
l'équivalent d'un tiers voire de la
moitié de la surface de la france qui
documentent à peu près complètement
l'évolution des amniotes depuis le
carbonifère mais surtout pendant le
permien et le trias et même encore un
peu pendant le début du jurassique
donc on a toute cette période la
dévolution de la première grande
radiation évolutif des amiotte qui est
très très bien documenté dans cette
région du caroux avec des couches vous
voyez qui sont pas pas particulièrement
très déformée donc on a d une
préservation qui est très très très
bonne dans des anciens dépôts de plaines
d'inondation des anciens dépôts de
marais il ya même un désert tout à la
fin vers la main vers le jurassique vers
le début du jurassique avant que la lave
ne recouvre tout donc là les laves du
drakensberg essentiellement située au
lesotho avant que ces laves ne recouvre
tout le quart ou était déjà devenu un
désert recouvert de gigantesques dunes
mais même là on trouve quand même des
squelettes de dinosaures des tout
premiers dinosaures donc c'est vraiment
une
une étendue à ses formidables et donc
quand vous prenez les groupes majeurs
d'animaux moderne de tétrapodes moderne
que ce soit mammifères tortue croco
oiseaux les arrêts et autres ils ont
tous au moins un ancêtre qui est
représentée enfin un représentant de
basale de leur famille qui est
représenté dans des couches qui date de
l'époque du 40
donc là par contre je vais m'étendre là
dessus là je vais prendre du temps donc
maintenant la classification de ces
amniotes donc vous avez vu tout à
l'heure pas liées au tourisme donc pas
les hôtes iris il est très représentatif
de la de l'anatomie du crâne
chez les premiers amiotte qui est la
morphologie du crâne la plus simple
qu'on puisse avoir à savoir un oeil un
trous pour le nez et c'est tout et les
autres amniotes en fête et de pendant
leur évolution du coup les amiotte vont
être amenés à développer de nouvelles
ouvertures dans leur crâne
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure donc le à
la base c'est le muscle perrigault id
qui permet la fermeture de la mâchoire
mais il y a un autre muscle qui
s'appelle le muscle temporal et qui se
trouve là dessous sous le crâne est en
fait la fonction de fermeture de la
mâchoire ben vas chez plein d'espèces en
fait j'ai plein de groupes
elle va shift et du muscle perrigault
ide au muscle temporal et ce chiffre est
en fait va se va se traduire sur la
morphologie du crâne par des ouvertures
de fos qui vont augmenter la surface
d'assertions musculaire pour home ce qui
permet d'augmenter la puissance de la
fermeture de la mâchoire donc déjà déjà
il ya une chose qu'il faut réaliser
c'est que tout ça ça va se faire chez
des carnivores donc après ça veut pas
dire qu'il ya pas des herbivores qui
vont évoluer à partir de ces formes
carnivores mais tout ça ça va être
essentiellement une évolution guidés par
des adaptations à la carne ivory déjà ça
c'est la première chose le faut bien se
repose d'ailleurs jeudi car niveau rim
et c'est même essentiellement un accès
ctive ory en tout cas pour les plus
petites formes surtout au début
en fait de l'évolution des amis note le
les insectes il y en a tellement en fait
et vous imaginez que les âmes notent ils
sont arrivés sur des continents où il
n'y avait pas d' insectivores avant eux
à part d'autres insectes et d'autres et
d'autres arthropodes comme les araignées
les scorpions mais en gros il sera
arrivé sur un continent sur des
continents où il n'y avait pas d'
insectivores de grande taille
donc vous imaginez ça d'un seul coup ça
a été le ca a été logique donc l'insecte
ça a été le fuel le carburant de
l'évolution des amniotes du début à la
fin ça l'est toujours aujourd'hui les
petits les petits animaux insectivores
sont bien plus diversifié que les gros
animaux que les gros animaux herbivores
ou ce que vous voulez donc c'est
vraiment la secte ivory c'est le fuel de
l'évolution des des tétrapodes et même
les animaux plus gros se nourrissent
beaucoup d'animaux plus petits qui
mangent eux mêmes des insectes
donc il ya ya qu une fois que les
herbivores de grandes tailles vont se
développer qu'on va un peu brisé
on va diminuer l'importance des insectes
dans l'évolution des amis note donc à
partir notamment des grands dinosaures
mais aussi à partir de cynapsys comme
les dinos et fall etc
mais il ya vraiment que quand l'herbe
ivory va devenir un peu plus près
prédominante au sein d
la diversité des régimes alimentaires
qu'on va vraiment avoir un shift ii de
cette importance des insectivores on va
dire dans l'évolution mais si vous
regardez l'évolution des synapses cite
par exemple à chaque fois tout redémarre
à partir de petit insectivore notamment
après la après la grande extinction
permis à trias vous aviez des herbivores
comme lady sino donc mais l'évolution
des synapses id elle va reprendre
surtout à partir des petits synodaux
petit 6,90 qui vont se re diversifiée à
partir de formes insectivores forme
insectivores qui vont redonner des
formes d'herbivores qui vont être les
six nominés qui vont redonner des formes
carnivore qui seront les pros beknown
yat et ses formes insectivores herbivore
vont subir une nouvelle extinction qui
hélas l'extinction triassique jurassique
et à partir de là laissez encore à
partir des insectivores que ça va se
développer donc les pro b nonya devons
donner les mammifères et les mammifères
étaient des petits insectivores et vont
redonner naissance à de nouveaux
herbivores et de nouveaux carnivores et
c'est donc c'est à chaque fois
en tout cas en tout cas sur la fin du
paléozoïque et le début du mésozoïque
c'est vraiment la secte ivory qui sera
au coeur de l'évolution des amniotes
bref après cette audi gression j'en
reviens à mes type crânien donc la
classification des amniotes elle est
basée essentiellement sur les types
crânien qui vont découler du
développement du muscle du muscle
temporal des muscles temporaux
d'ailleurs il ya plusieurs là plusieurs
muscles dans la tempe
mais voilà c'est la classification des
amis note est basé sur la fenestration
temporal key elle-même découle du
développement des muscles temporaux et 7
fenestration temporal bas elle et elle
est de 5 types comme vous voyez à
l'écran
donc le premier type c'est le type
primitif le type annappes sites comme je
voulais dit c'est ce qui vient de ce
palais au thierry c'était comme ça ils
ono mus c'était comme ça et les
amphibiens été comme ça un trou pour les
yeux un trous pour le nez et c'est la
fin
ensuite vous avez le les crânes qui
n'ont qu'une seule fausse temporal les
synapses ide et les oreilles apside la
différence étant que les synapses id la
fosse temporal est en position basse
donc sur le côté du crâne
alors que chez les heures et abside elle
est en position haute sur le dessus du
crâne donc généralement quand on regarde
le crâne sur le côté on le voit on voit
pas la fausse temporal là ce que je vous
ai représenter c'est évidemment
schématique
c'est juste pour être cohérent
visuellement on va dire et ensuite vous
avez la combinaison des deux c'est à
dire les dix apside avec deux fosses
temporal la haute et la basse encore
plus de surface d'insertion musculaire
et enfin vous avez dérivé du type dit
apside le type archosaures chez le type
archosaures c'est plus une question de
fausses temporal c'est une question de
fausses mandibulaire et il ya une fosse
à l'avant de l'oeil la fosse
mandibulaire ça on peut encore
raisonnablement dire que c'est de
l'insertion de muscles
par contre la fausse en torby terre l'a
donc la fenêtre ou fenêtres en théorie
terre on peut dire fausses ou cheveux
naître c'est vrai que c'est plus
pertinent de dire fenêtre mais en
français ça va pas tellement
d'importance en anglais c'est plus
important de dire fenêtre mais en
français on peut dire fausses la plupart
des gens disent fausses ça n'a pas
vraiment d'importance
sachez qu'on peut intervertir
complètement les mots fausses et
fenêtres dans ce cas là voilà donc cette
cette fenêtre en théorie terre si vous
préférez elle et elle est allée située à
l'avant de leur [ __ ] mais elle n'est pas
vraiment pour une assertion musculaire
et on ne sait pas on sait pas si bien
que ça en fait parce que les crocodiles
n'ont pas de fenêtre en théorie terre et
chez les oiseaux cette fenêtre en orbite
air et fusionnée à l'oeil et elle est
très réduite donc et c'est les seuls
archosaures moderne qu'on ait
aujourd'hui donc on sait pas vraiment ce
qu on sait pas vraiment à quoi elle sert
elle servait cette fenêtre en orbite à
aller très développée chez les
dinosaures théropodes les dinosaures
théropodes ils vont même avoir une
fenêtre en théorie terre et encore une
autre fenêtre qui va s'ouvrir à l'avant
de la fenêtre en terre orbitaire mais on
sait pas trop à quoi ça servait mais
voilà donc si vous avez une fenêtre en
position haute vous êtes un e ri apside
en position basse vous êtes un synappci
d2
si vous avez les deux fenêtres vous
atteint 10 absil et si vous avez un
supplément
andy bull est en théorie terre vous avez
un menu archosaures voilà en gros
comment ça se passe maintenant on peut
voir les faut voir la distribution de
ces types en fonction du temps et de la
phylogénie et là ça devient là ça
devient sérieusement bordel c'est pour
ça aussi que j'insiste pas trop sur la
phylogénie c'est parce que là ça devient
ça devient limite de l'art déco alors
les synapses it c'est pas compliqué
voyait les synapses idy sont là une fois
sans une fausse temporal en position
basse
et ça le reste donc vous avez les amis
est ici la division fondamentale entre
les soro psy délai synappci donc entre
les reptiles et la lignée qui donnera
les mammifères et en gros vous avez un
crâne qui n'a pas de fenêtre vous allez
sur la branche cynapsys vous avez une
fausse une fosse qui grandit une fosse
qui grandit une fosse qui devient très
grosse et qui devient gigantesque chez
les mammifères tellement grande qu'elle
va fusionner avec l'oeil d'ailleurs donc
ça c'est pas compliqué c'est les
synapses it ça va tout va bien par
contre de l'autre côté c'est l'e sour
oxyde et alors là c'est la teuf donc les
sorts oxydes au début vous avez in home
us et paléo thirith par exemple qui
n'ont pas de fausses et vous avez tout
un groupe qui s'appelle les paras
reptile dont la plupart des membres
n'ont pas de fenêtre de fausses si vous
préférez ce qui n'est pas ce qui est
déjà une grosse simplification parce que
chez les paras reptiles on en a qui ont
des fenêtres temporal et on en a même
des sacrés des sacrément embêtant
d'ailleurs parce qu'il ressemble
beaucoup à décines apside lantana sus
par exemple c'est vraiment à gaspiller
celui là voilà je ne résiste pas à
l'envié de vous montrer lambda n'a su ce
donc lanthane asus c'est un para
reptiles on le sait parce que la
morphologie de son palais la morphologie
de ces dans tout ça c'est complètement
cohérent avec un sort oxydes par contre
quand on regarde le dessus du crâne
le crâne est plat arrondie avec des
petits trous partout donc ça fait très
amphibiens et ici vous avez l'oeil et là
vous avez la fosse temporal en position
non pas sur le dessus parce que sinon
elle serait là donc en position basse
comme un synapses id
donc le machin c'est un patchwork de
caractère de parra red steel 2
caractères de synapses ide et de
caractère de d'amphibiens donc les paras
reptiles c'est des cochonneries
c'est des cochonneries et honnêtement à
chaque fois que quelqu'un met le nez
dans leur classification
il ressort en pleurant ou en étant
dépressif c'est cette une
c'est une catastrophe lantin astuces ça
vient de russie d'ailleurs donc c'est un
petit cadeau des russes voient là c'est
le synappci date est d'amphibiens qui
est en fait un pas rares et peut-il donc
les paras reptiles c'est c'est de l'art
déco c'est de l'art moderne
ils font ce qu'ils veulent ensuite on
arrive au dioxyde les lits apside ils
sont un petit peu plus sage des dioxydes
ils développent leurs deux fosses
temporal d'ailleurs vous remarquerez que
il n'y a pas de stade intermédiaire
entre pas de fossé de fausses donc ils
développent leurs deux fenêtres temporal
et et puis vous avez une branche qui va
donner les pid aux or donc ce qu'on
appelle les lézards les serpents etc
chez lesquels les fausses temporal vont
rester globalement présente pas trop
altéré sauf chez les serpents bien sûr
où c'est la fête du slip du crâne et
vous avez de l'autre côté la branche qui
va mener aux archosaures sur lesquels on
trouve sur laquelle on trouve les
tortues parce que les archosaures et les
tortues forment le groupe d art queloz
oria et les tortues est bon elles vont
rétro pédaler jusqu'à la condition en
abside donc pendant des années on a cru
que les tortues étaient en abside parce
qu'elle était là voilà et notamment
peut-être des petites cousines départ et
ils n'ont en fait les tortues elles sont
tous là haut
à côté d'eux les archosaures et elles
ont juste rétro pédaler vers une
condition adapted est ici vous avez les
archosaures qui sont qui ont leur
condition d'y abside modifié donc si là
il fallait mettre des petites flèches en
gros la condition annappes sidon la
condition sine abside et la condition
d'y apside et la condition d'y apside
redonne ensuite la condition archosaures
et là encore j ai pas inclus dans ce
petit arbre et the ring side les
oreilles à petit qu'ils sont
essentiellement des reptiles marins du
mésozoïque chez qui en fait c'est pas la
condition and apside qui a donné la
condition e ri abside en fait c'est la
condition à la petite qui a donné la
condition d'y ap six décès la condition
d'y abside qui a rétropédalé vers la
condition eury abside donc là ils ont
perdu en fait la fosse temporal
inférieure ce que c'est ce que vous
voyez ici c'est cette petite encoche là
c'est censé représenter le résidu de la
fosse temporal inférieur donc c'est
compliqué quand on regarde la phylogénie
donc c'est pour ça que moi là pour
secours
je vais suivre une classification encore
une fois non phylogénétique donc je vais
prendre des groupes
je vais groupe aimer espèces et mes
familles en fonction de l'anatomie du
crâne pour avoir des groupes
anatomiquement cohérent encore une fois
mais qu'ils sont pas forcément
phylogénétiquement très cohérent à part
pour les tortues je vais faire une
exception pour les tortues parce que
c'est quand même important de rappeler
que les tortues sont dédits abside à la
base mais voilà ça donc
donc ne venait pas encore une fois râler
dans les commentaires parce que j'ai pas
suivi la phylogénie et machin je suis
tout à fait conscient de la phylogénie
c'est juste que encore une fois à ce
niveau là mes étudiants ne sont pas
censés avoir eu de cours de philo génie
donc ou du moins une partie de mes
étudiants ceux venant de géologie ne
sont pas censés avoir eu cours de philo
génie donc ils sont pas censés
comprendre tout ça donc ça c'est juste
le petit arbre que je leur monde pour
leur dire ça c'est ce que je vais vous
apprendre ça c'est ce qu'il va falloir
que vous sachiez à la fin une fois que
vous aurez eu vos cours de philo génie
vous reviendrez assez court là parce que
je viens de vous dire et vous vous direz
ben oui mais oui c'est ça qui s'est
passé en fait même est là pour l'instant
ce n'est pas le but c'est pas le but du
tout et vous allez voir que ses tresses
et suffisamment compliqué comme ça donc
c'est la fameuse le fameux schéma avec
justement les les types crânien qui
évoluent les uns par rapport aux autres
donc à nab sidon les synapses ide et les
dioxines et les dioxines reviennent vers
les oréades side et les archosaures et
il manque même une flèche pour dire que
dit ah ben si tu peux coffre
évoluer dans l'autre sens berrada psid
donc bon mais même aujourd'hui même je
devrai aussi faire une flèche qui repart
de archosaures pour redonner en abside
parce que les oiseaux sont des
archosaures mais vous pouvez toujours
chercher ses fausses temporal chez les
oiseaux les oiseaux ils ont plus de
fausses mandibulaire ils ont plus de
fausses temporal et ils ont ils ont là
fo santé orbitaire qui est fusionné perd
presque imperceptible ça dépend dans les
espèces les canards ça se voie
relativement bien mais en tout cas la
fosse la haye les fusionner avec l'oeil
ce qui fait que j'ai beaucoup d'espèces
allait complètement imperceptible donc
le crâne fonctionnellement chez les
oiseaux il est un acide il ya aucune
fenêtre dedans donc on pourrait même
mettre une autre flèche là qui
remonteraient jusqu'ici sans aucun
problème on a des exemples de diab side
qui reviennent à un type de crâne apside
comme par exemple le monstre de gila il
a un crâne quand vous regardez le crâne
le crâne il a aucune ouverture il est
parce que parce que le crâne est
complètement recouvert d'ostéo d'herbe
en fait y compris les deux fosses tente
orale et les osthéos derme c de la peau
aussi fier je précise et vous avez
certains synappci des rongeurs par
exemple des mammifères des rongeurs
pareil ils ont des grosses ostéo derme
sur le crâne
donc le nom du bestiau celle aux filles
aux miss le rat à crête et le rat à
crête il appareille de la peau aussi
fier de lost et au derme qui rendent son
crâne visuellement and abside donc à on
vous pourriez en fait vous pourriez
mettre des flèches dans tous les sens
donc c'est pour ça que je laisse tomber
un peu l'histoire des flèches que je
préfère vous montrer la phylogénie mans
même si je suis pas censé parler
phylogénie mais il faut savoir à ce
moment là que ça c'est mignon mais c'est
pas si simple
c'est me c'est très pratique ça a été
très pratique pendant très longtemps
vous retrouverez cette classification
basée sur les types crâniens dans des
dents des vieux bouquins c'est la
classification ici que je choisi de
suivre parce que c'est la plus simple et
la plus cohérente anatomiquement parce
que ce qu'on veut c'est quand même des
caractères qui permettent d'identifier
vos bestioles quand vous les trouvez sur
le terrain 1 pour les paléontologues
c'est quand même ça qui est intéressant
c'est de pouvoir identifier ce que vous
trouvez quand vous êtes sur le terrain
donc voilà je préfère utiliser quelques
une classification qui et
morphologiquement cohérente plutôt que
phylogénétiquement cohérente mais il
faut savoir que phylogénétiquement c'est
c'est une purge
et voilà c'est la fin de cette de
secours sur l'origine des amniotes sur
l'or sur les amphibiens et l'origine des
amiotte j'espère que ça a été
relativement clair que ça n'a pas été
trop confus c'est probablement le court
le plus difficile parce que déjà les
amniotes et l'origine des amniotes et
des amphibiens c'est pas exactement la
partie la plus motivante du truc du
court je dire je sais bien que ce que
vous attendez c'est les dinosaures c'est
bon je sais bien que ce que tout le
monde veut c'est qu'on en arrive aux
dinosaures j'arrive on en arrive c'est
la prochaine c'est dans les prochains
cours mais voilà c'est un des coups les
plus durs parce que il fait appel à
beaucoup de caractère très très
technique donc à partir du prochain
cours on attaquera les europe side et
les synapses il en fait j'ai déjà fait
une vidéo sur les synapses it donc les
deux branches de des deux grandes
branches des amiotte j'en ai déjà
couvert une complètement donc j'ai déjà
fait un cours de presque deux heures sur
les synapses id
donc je peux vous en je peux vous
envoyer vers un lien qui vous emmènera
voir ma vidéo que j'ai déjà fait sur
l'évolution des synapses id là ce qu'on
va faire c'est qu'on va focaliser sur
les sort oxydes pour les prochains cours
et ensuite on attaquera la paléontologie
du caroux avant de se quitter il ya
quelque chose que je vais dire
maintenant et que je redirai dans mon
prochain cours etc
prenez bien garde à reptiles évolution
d'autres comme ea ptérosaures hérésie ce
sont des sites qui proposent des images
très des très très belle reconstitution
est généralement si vous cherchez des
reconstitutions d'animaux préhistoriques
enfin des squelettes d'animaux
préhistoriques notamment si ce sont des
reptiles vous allez tomber sur des
images qui viennent de au moins un de
ces deux cités en fait ces deux sites
sont réalisés par exactement la même
personne et autant il y en a certains
qui sont bien 20 ans il ya des
reconstitutions qui sont bien autant il
y en a beaucoup qui sont très mauvaises
et je sais moi d'expérience que beaucoup
de mes étudiants vont juste googlers
squelette de machin chouette
ils vont prendre la première image du
machin chouette qui ressort et cette
première image de macha chouette vient
d'un de ces deux sites
et ça non seulement ça se voit tout de
suite qu'ils n'ont pas vérifié si le
squelette était était bien reconstituée
mais en plus ça se voit immédiatement
que ça vient de d'annoncer deux sites
parce que s'il ya un style graphique
très évident
donc c'est vraiment des sites dont je
recommande pas vraiment l'utilisation et
à chaque fois que vous faites des
recherches google pour des
reconstitutions squelettiques vérifiez
bien que qu'ils ne viennent pas de ces
sites
quitte à la limite à prendre des
reconstructions qui viennent de bouquins
anciens elles sont pas toujours très
très juste non plus ses vieilles
reconstitution mais au moins vous pouvez
citer votre source
alors que là si vous citez le reptile
évolutions et aux ptérosaures hérésie et
qu'il ya une erreur on vous aura tout de
suite on vous regardera tout de suite en
disant vous aviez capot prendra part
là-bas parce que c'est on sait que c'est
nul et tout le monde le sait qu tu vois
là donc faites bien attention à ces deux
sites
faites attention à vous et je vous dis à
la prochaine fois